we're Thomas Jefferson High School we
just got done shopping that Sports
Authority
and let me tell you what we're gonna
surprise him with gifts today
oh we know we got to have the wear
jersey be the smaller shoulder pads ever
seen are you kidding me we go into the
next level I want to dress up as a high
school football player and we want to
surprise in the day I'm going to sell
the story that is we got a new player
coming in from Dallas Texas we're really
excited about him but we all had got
called down for a meeting like none of
us knew what we were gonna be having a
meeting about I was proud of the season
that you had I know it wasn't exactly
what you were hoping and so I really
wanted to find something to excite you
guys for the offseason and I think I
recruited a pretty good athlete to help
us next year he's a transfer from Dallas
Texas he's about 64 to 60 but doing some
big surprise
get ready Marcus Saks for Marcus did you
come in please
when I first walked in the room they
looked at me like man this is a guy
who's gonna steal my position I said
hold on hold on
I understand it's the 66 chairs it's
throwing you guys off so you know threw
it off and put the 94 Jersey on I heard
everybody room this explode we're all
excited about this new recruit and
DeMarcus Ware head came in we're all
really surprised you know DeMarcus Ware
everybody if the workers thought our
team this week we go to state for sure
right we definitely go to state on
behalf of the Denver Broncos and our
Sports Authority they teamed up and they
gave you guys you know some some good
equipment this is like a second chance
for you guys we've really faced a lot of
difficult budget cuts this is just
really incredible and really generous of
DeMarcus and the Denver Broncos to help
us with this I think is not just taking
time outside of football and it just was
a great opportunity to spray some joy
there you go boy
I like that